Alright, so what we're going to do to figure
out how Q learning works, is we're going to think
about what it means to estimate this Q function
from transitions. So, let's just remember this is the
form of the Q equation, that we've been
talking about. And, we can't do this. We can't
solve this, because we don't have access to R
and T. All we have access to are transitions.
>> So this a really, I guess, I'm going to
guess you said this before, but when you, when you
write out this equation it really jumps out at
me. This is the difference between what I was talking
about, solving MDPs and reinforcement learning. In solving MDPs
we had R and we had T and now we
do not have them, so we have to come up
with some other way to solve these kinds of equations.
>> That's right.
>> Okay. So if we did have R and T, then we could solve this?
>> Yeah, this is, I mean, the same
things that you talked about, value iteration, policy iteration?
It can be formulated in terms of Q. So it's, yeah, there's,
this is easy to do, well, [LAUGH] it's polynomial to do if
you have access to T and R. But but again, in the
learning scenario we don't have the model. What we have are transitions.
>> Okay, okay.
>> So, here's how we're going to use transitions. This
is what a transition is. We, we observe that we
were in some state S of the MDP. And then
action A was chosen somehow. And, then a transition happens.
We land in a state. We get the reward for landing
in that state. And we find out what state we're in. So
that's, that's the transition. And what are we going to do with
it? Well, what we're going to do. Is imagine that we've got an
estimate of the Q function, Q hat, and we're going to update
it as follows. Here's how we're going to use all these quantities from
the transition. We're going to take the, the state and action that
we just experienced. And we're going to change it; we going to update it;
we're going to move a little bit. Alpha, this is alpha,
this is called a learning rate. We're going to move a
little bit in the direction of the immediate reward plus
the discounted estimated value of the next state. So, we're going to
take our estimate Q hat, we going to take the state
that we end up in as prime. We're going to look at
all the different actions we could take from there and
take the maximum. So this together is kind of an estimate
of the utility, right?
>> Mm-hm.
>> And this is the utility of the state that we're
going to. This altogether is the utility of the state that,
that we're in. To the state S. So this is kind
of the utility of the state that we're landing in as
prime. And this all together is, is related to the utility
of the state, right? You can see that it's related. In
that we've got the immediate reward, which kind of matches to
this. We've got the discounting. We don't have the sum over transitions
but we do have the max A and the lookup in the
next, in the Q function. Alright so this, this is the Q
learning equation. Alright, let me just say a little bit more about
this, this alpha arrow notation, which I really like but is not
all that standard. So if you, when I write you know something
like V gets with an alpha X. What we mean is we're
moving alpha of the way from the current value V towards X,
which can be written this way. That V gets 1 minus alpha
of V plus alpha of x. And so in particular, if
you think about this as so if alpha is 0. That's
sort of a learning rate of 0, which shouldn't learn at
all, and in fact, if you set alpha to 0 here, it's
going to zero out X, and it's going to only assign V to
V, so nothing's going to change. So learning rate of 0
corresponds to no learning. And if we set alpha to 1,
that's like full learning, so we forget everything that we knew and
we just jumped to the new value. And that's
what happens here, that 1 minus alpha is 0,
so the V goes away, and we just get X assigned to V. So does that make sense?
>> That does make sense. And and if alpha
were in between 0 and 1 like one half, you're
basically making V the average of the old value
of V, and the new value X that you see.
>> Good.